Blake's hairless chest Garrett's big
promise Jason's pursed lips these were
the fantasy suites and it's time for
roses and Rose a you guys Thailand of
course we are here recapping Becca
Cooper in season of The Bachelorette
thank you for joining me here roses in
Rose a and he it was the fantasies so we
are going to dive right in because this
episode was nuts it's taking a while but
we're getting there to some nut ball
drama what did you think of fantasy
suites did live up to your expectations
did you want more sexiness or more
sadness let me know in the comments big
reveal big bomb off the top we knew that
Becca was in love with Blake but it's
just kind of tossed in in the beginning
there she's in love with Garrett to
Garrett Wow can you give a girl a heads
up I mean they just they just they just
sprinkled it in there it really makes me
wonder what the editing has been like
you know because we see Becca say things
like my heart recognizes his maybe she
was talking about Garrett where those
phrases taken and made to seem to be
about Blake at some points I don't know
at what point did she fall in love with
Garrett vs. Blake who did she fall in
love with first I guess it'd be like but
anyways cuz she's in love with two men
then she gives Jason a little
consolation prize by saying they have a
quote just off the charts ostrich arts
connection okay well your heart is
recognizing other people's hearts so bad
she says she knows he loves her she's
falling in love with him but she's so
far ahead with Blake and Garrett so we
know where this is going it's going down
the river there's a river in this
episode anyway first we have Blake and
Becca says that she is 100% myself and
it's so
and then it's effortless don't drink
every time Becca says something super
significant about Garrett or Blake or
even Jason she keeps saying these really
strong statements that make it seem like
she's totally one-way and then she says
similar things about another guy so what
do you think are you confused on Becca's
feelings at this point do you think that
she's leaning to Blake or Garrett let me
know what you guys think in the comments
because I thought it was awkward when
they first saw each other they're like
touching but not touching like holding
hands and like where's it's so awkward
and then we find out they're gonna go on
a hike for hiking but on the hike they
can't touch or kiss each other because
bigger temple alright I'd pick a
different hike they hike up somewhere
and they see a monk and I want to read
what Becca said quote there's something
so old about interacting with a monk
it's honestly not like anything I've
ever seen before well have you met a
monk before probably not so it is
something you've never seen before well
I definitely miss to the hottest CMLL
Becca says that honesty is the most
important thing to her and she's brought
up Ari again are we oh I just I'm sorry
are we still talking about
he-who-must-not-be-named
it's near the finale at this point we
don't need to discuss him also
Blake is very sweaty that's it I don't
know how Becca's makeup stayed so match
the whole time it was very mad but Blake
was very moist
I know people hate that word you haven't
lost all it in the most consistent
to the point where I feel like if it's
too good to be true too good to be true
you're saying you want honesty and you
want a great guy now it's too good to be
true
I'm confused Beca I'm confused
I guess maybe it's because she trusted
he-who-must-not-be-named and he was
saying all the things she wanted here
and then it turned out she shouldn't
have trusted him okay I just figured it
out never mind sorry I didn't say it I
said sorry
back up gosh I can't stop quoting her
tonight drink every time I quote Becca
don't do it Becca says that she needs to
knock on wood because she's so worried
that something was gonna come to go so
she says give me all the wood give me
all the wood that's not what then Blake
comes in with a much better line he
tells her quote I'm the kind of guy who
the kind of man who looks for reason to
stay that was the reason I wrote that is
that from the sequel to the notebook
dude
is that from the sequel to win Harry Met
Sally is that from the sequel to pretty
woman is that from the sequel to you've
got mail I wanted it to be news is that
from the sequel to Sleepless in Seattle
is that from the sequel to working girl
I'm naming all my favorite rom-coms do
not drink every time someone wear their
shoes on a bed in this episode then they
wake up in the morning and Becca's
makeup looks matte and perfect drink
every time she looks matte and perfect
mm-hmm I'm giving you guys a lot of
drink nicknames is nothing so be careful
just like she says we're in love with
him
and it seems really sweet and genuine
just like Becca is big statement though
I mean almost Gareth it's not everything
up next sir again this is serious fear
but more importantly perhaps where is
Blake's chest hair where's everyone's
chest hair
are they waxing because they have so
much free time during filming where is
it I need to know so Jason's looking
cute I like his shoes and probably from
the combination of gel in his hair and
the humidity I mean his hair looks
soaking wet at this point it's never
looked more extreme but on this date
they eat some bugs some crickets
Jason is all-in on back guys and what I
want to be her and she's having a good
time with Jason until those leftovers at
home Enter the Dragon
and a large stone dragon is out set of
what I believe to be a temple there's so
many temples in this episode don't drink
every time you see a temple and back and
make some kind of offhanded comment like
could you see that dragon outside of our
house but it's like no where are you
living
I think Jason lives in New York or see
how or something here contouring shadow
no don't put that out there but home
decor choices aside the issue is that
this little comment makes her lose it
everything was going great as she likes
to say she was having the best time but
saying that and she was the one who said
it made her think about the moment I
feel like they couldn't see him in that
picture don't drink every time
Becca talks about seeing the future in
this episode the word future is gonna be
just you'll be knocked out it says so I
don't know I promise right now let's
just but we got something that I
absolutely love here we broke the fourth
wall I love when they do this a producer
talks to Becca Becca's like I'm feeling
weird don't drink every time she says
she feels weird I'm in my head don't
drink every time anybody says that on
this show I don't know what to do I'm
confused I don't know why I'm feeling
like this I'd just be aware just so
we're just happening and it's her
connection with Jason unraveling that's
what we're gonna say in front of us and
the producers they're kind of talking
her through and they she's going to
squat down they always gonna squat down
and like talk and like kind of play with
their hair wow it was a good moment I
love it tear down the fourth wall they
don't always do it and so I think that
when they do it that makes it really
powerful
and I loved how when Becca was talking
about how weird she felt he just kept
cutting back to Jason and just like
chillin here just trying to like drink
water and stay hydrated so they're at
dinner and Becca finally acknowledges to
Jason that she's feeling a little off
gets up and walks away from the table
and says she can't breathe do not drink
every time Becca paces around on this
episode stressfully mm-hmm
yes I could see a future with Jason but
Jason tries to convince her to stay this
conversation was weird wasn't it Becca
said she wanted to give Jason a reason
but she couldn't and I could see he was
confused and shocked I'd be remiss if I
didn't ask but you're confident that you
don't see a future with us no I'm not
happy and so we're going to recreate it
tonight on the journey with JC Jason
your hair is so slicked back I just want
to give you a reason I can't even
explain what I'm feeling but I don't
know how to tell you the reason but
what's the reason I know that I have a
reason but I don't know how to say the
reason and I hate doing that to anyone
but do you have a reason I have a reason
but I can't give you the reason it's the
one thing I want to give to you but I
can't I don't know how to what to say to
do am I the reason okay thank you JC
Thank You JC JC stands for Jason
creation it doesn't but anyways I came
under this ruling for happiness I always
leave room for happiness god that's good
I just get somebody a nanny on this show
the most dramatic that he got was he he
pursed his lips in the weirdest way in
the limo the weirdest way I was like is
this him trying not to cry I don't know
anyway Becca also says quote I literally
just did to him that could no you didn't
drink every time she's too hard on
herself so the morning after Jason and
whether she's in the fantasy suite or
not Becca is on the couch and is she
conscious tough call lots of shots with
her where I was questioning it her eyes
are closed they're still closed she's in
the fetal position we've got a weird
beauty and the beast' type vase on the
table what's in that vase cake pops
I don't want a cake pop oh my god she's
awake she got up yeah I was worried
so she runs up and she wraps her legs
around Garrett a nice thought she
wrapped her legs around Blake to the
jump and wrap wrapped her legs around
Garrett did he do it with Jason well
he's gone they are gonna go bamboo
rafting I guess that's the thing and
it's a Thai national holiday there are
rafts and people everywhere you guys
they kept trying to make it seem like
the state was fun but it looks so
stressful to me there's a woman on our
phone is that phone gonna get wet
they're like screaming children there's
elephants very near small children is
that phone gonna get wet I was concerned
Garrett has still not told Becca he's in
love with her I kind of forgot about
this I have to say in Garrett's defense
he got kind of a garbage date first a
nasty river and now they're sitting on
the ground for his fantasy suite rich
reminded me of Becca's fantasy with
you-know-who and they were like a tent
but anyway and she tells him that she
would not have wanted to go down the
river with anyone else at these
statements she also told Jason she
wouldn't have wanted to eat bugs with
anyone else
is that true there's no one else you'd
want to eat bugs with or go down a river
with this is confusing for these guys I
will say that while he who must not be
named said I love you to both Lauren and
Becca and that was big she is making
statements that are very definitive very
definitive and very long-term to these
guys and I think that's confusing
Becca then says that he who must not be
named was not equal and not the 50/50
partner she wanted shocking not really
yes I see this my career is I can go
anywhere I'm not stuck a hundred percent
like in my ways of where I'm living here
and here was an issue I had Garrett very
quickly said that he would be able to
move his job and yeah he's open
everything didn't he take her like on a
tractor in his hometown and talk about
living on the farm what is his job can
he move that tractor around
okay then Garrett says he has never felt
this happy Wow and tells Becca he's in
love with her
love you and then he says that she
didn't say it but he could tell she
loved him by the way that she just
kissed me that's a dangerous game to
play don't interpret people's feelings
by things other than words
oh she also says that she sees Garrett
as her hearts equal to some kind of
special person remember she said with
Blake that her heart recognized his
these statements and then Jason is back
why I don't know because I guess he
didn't get the reasons or the answers
but I didn't feel that this conversation
helped at all did you guys after Jason's
return with this weird scrapbook did you
think that he got the answers he was
looking for from Becca let me know this
is one thing I want to give you before I
left I was gonna give it to you the
night of our day and the scrapbook is
very organized do you think Jason really
made that scrapbook please weigh in I
couldn't tell okay then we have the last
rose ceremony is just Blake and Garrett
and they both seem annoyed to be looking
at each other I wonder if they're
friends at this point do they start
Prime's fantasy suites in Thailand and
it was the land of confusion and drama
how'd everyone feel about fantasy suites
I like to this episode and I do think
the finale is going to be very dramatic
because I think Blake and Garrett are
both very invested in Becca and I want
to know who do you guys think she picks
we're down to the final two now of
course we have men tell all first next
week and I will have some interviews
shameless plug from mental all up at et
online calm and on the entertainment
tonight because we there I was at the
tape thing we did the interviews and got
some scoop and then we'll have the
finale this has been such a season
everybody we have come to the exciting
end so stick with us thank you so much
for watching and reach out to me any
time to talk Bachelorette and really
anything else love you bye
[Music]